ich würde jetzt noch mal doch
widersprechen also wenn erstens finde
ich die die Argumentation völlig absurd
zu sagen ja der Span hat das damals
falsch gemacht und jetzt muss der
Lauterbach dann deswegen zurücktreten
also entweder sparen oder Lauterbach in
der man muss den Kontext sehen die
damalige Situation war das völlig
idiotische Impfgegner Thesen aufgestellt
haben die völlig absurd waren und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass jemand wieder
Lauterbach dann sagt gegen diese im hoch
gefährlich und bloß nicht impfen und so
gesagt hat die ist nebenwirkungsfrei
jeder der sich wissenschaftlich auskennt
weiß sowas gibt es nie eine ein ein
Medikament das keine Nebenwirkung hat
hat das ist ein Grundsatz der
Pharmakologie auch keine
Wirkung
momentan
korrigiert und ich fand viel wichtiger
und im Nachhinein jetzt zu sagen wir
haben das viel zu wenig Daten es war
damals so wir wissen das noch alles es
war damals so dass die Leute befestigt
waren ich bekomme keine Impfung die
einen ja die anderen waren gegen die
Impfung in dieser Situation wo man ganz
schnell also normalerweise wenn
Impfstoff zehn Jahre lang entwickelt was
hätte es in Deutschland für ein Aufstand
gegeben wenn wir zehn Jahre gebraucht
hätten und da gab es dann natürlich auch
Dinge ich stimme Ihnen ja insofern zu
dass man wahrscheinlich der srki z.B
Robert Kochen hätte viel mehr
Untersuchungen machen müssen die z.B
steht auch versucht hat zu machen
man hat versucht sehr schnell eine eine
dramatische Situation die wir die
Menschheit noch nie hatte zu managen und
dass da auch mal Fehler vorkommen würde
ich zu billigen aber Lauterbach hat sich
immer bemüht die Öffentlichkeit auch
über den Stand der Wissenschaft zu
informieren
entschuldigt sich dann dafür dass er
sagt nein Formulierung
also erstens es geht nicht um die
Situation jetzt Ende November oder
Dezember 2020 bei der Einführung der des
Impfstoffes und die ganze Diskussion
davor da hatten wir noch gar kein
Impfstoff sondern es geht darum oder so
etwas das ab Ende 2000 Amperes 2021 mit
dem nächsten Lockdown auf einmal diese
imfrage und zwar nur in Deutschland in
dieser Gewalt zu einem dogmatischen
Thema gemacht worden ist wo sogar über
impfpflichten diskutiert worden ist es
ist weder in Norwegen noch in Schweden
oder sonst wo nur in Deutschland und
Österreich kam dieses Thema Impfpflicht
auf die Leute was völlig absurd war weil
für die Impfpflicht gab es überhaupt
mehr keine epilologische sonst welche
Begründung gut
das ist aber nicht einfach nein die
versuchen das im Bundestag nur was nur
an der CDU und Teilen der FDP
gescheitert ist die SPD und Grüne hätten
das einfach durchgezogen und da kann
sich doch kein Auto machen heute nicht
hinstellen ja das hat wollten wir ja gar
nicht ist ja Unsinn man kann ja seine
Bundestag reden sich noch anhören und
das ist genau das entscheidende Problem
würde diese Impfung in einer Art und
Weise
ideologisiert ich habe das ganze mal am
Anfang der Pandemie schon politische
Virologie genannt wo es überhaupt nicht
mehr um Medizin ging ja aber wenn dann
auf beiden Seiten ja es gab auch
nirgends so absurde Impfgegner wie in
Deutschland
noch
also dass ich ich warum konnten die
Jugend auf die Schnapsidee mich mit
irgendjemanden der in einen Topf zu
werfen der vielleicht irgendein
unsinnigen Gegner wie Impfgegner gab's
nicht aber ich will nicht ganz so sicher
schon verteidigt zu dieser Zeit würden
sie das heute mit dem Wissen von heute
anders beurteilen das ist ja immer die
gleiche Frage es gab keine Blaupause
dafür das ist Nummer 1 Nummer 2 ich
meine es geht ja hier bei Lauterbach um
was anderes und da geht's auch nicht um
die Frage Jens Spahn ja oder nein es
geht um die Frage des aktuellen
Verantwortlichen wenn ein Politiker
jemanden hinter die durchgeführt muss
ich einfach sagen gleite die komplette
Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik darum geht
es und das ist das Problem hier
selbstverständlich kann er am Schluss
sagen oh ich habe mich geirrt ich habe
neue Erkenntnisse da ändere ich was aber
dass er sich hinstellt und sagt er
eigentlich habe ich es ja vorher gewusst
und zwar anders das ist natürlich nicht
in Ordnung ich muss auch dazu sagen es
hat mich ja Familie selbst auch
getroffen mein Vater war im Pflegeheim
die ersten Impfstoffe kamen November
Dezember für die Pflegeeinrichtung mein
Vater ist gestorben im Januar weil er
nicht geimpft worden ist weil es genau
eine Woche zwei zu spät war da wird man
auch nie rausfinden was jetzt alleine
das war ganz andere Faktoren das wissen
wir einfach nicht das kann man nicht
sagen und zur damaligen Zeit war ich
tatsächlich der Auffassung dass man
zumindest in Pflegeeinrichtung bei den
ganzen Wohlen aber auch bei der Frage
derer die sie pflegen darüber nachdenken
muss ob man sie nicht verpflichten muss
zeitlich verpflichten muss weil sie ja
mit wohl eine Rahmen zu tun haben dort
eine Eindämmung vor Unternehmen nicht
für alle das kann man streitig stellen
das gebe ich zu aber auch da gab es
keine ich würde am heutigen wissen was
auf der Gesundheitsminister sind dass er
Impfschäden anerkennt ist die gibt es
würden sie dann müsste er normalerweise
jetzt die Konsequenz sehen und sagen ich
habe euch damals hinter die Fichte
geführt und dann sagen das wars
es geht nicht um die Frage Formulierung
gewährt gesagt das stimmt politischen
Geschäft sind müssen sie damit leben was
Sie gesagt haben aber ist natürlich
Unsinn also nebenwirkungsfreies Unsinn
bei jedem Medikament bei jeder Impfung
das kann man gar nicht sagen also ich
rede ja nicht über sie und sie müssen ja
auch gar nicht zurücktreten
es geht um die Frage der Funktion von
Karl Lauterbach und bitte das ist jetzt
natürlich doof das ist dann heißt er
sagt er jetzt so ich würde es bei meinen
genauso sagen und ich kann ihn nur sagen
auch eine Manuela Schwesig unmöglich und
bei vielen anderen auch das schadet der
politischen er hat der ganzen Kaste das
schadet uns allen wenn nicht in diesen
Funktionen konsequent gerade Linie auch
was gesagt wird und man natürlich zugibt
ja das war mein Gott falsch da aber so
Moment wir müssen ja schon ganz klar
ganz ernst sein man kann Wort falsch
sagen wir reden hier schon von Menschen
die unter umschäden leidigende Leben
zerstört ist und ja darum kämpfen dafür
Frank auch Anerkennung zu bekommen und
das ist aufgrund der Datenlage zunehmend
schwieriger weil man eben nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kann und einen langen
bürokratischen Weg gehen muss damit
dieser im Schaden auch anerkannt wird
ein ganz ganz erstes Thema bei dem
vielleicht nicht einfach nur mal ein
falsches Wort fallen darf ja genau und
deswegen verstehe auch nicht sie sagten
ebenso schön naja da haben corona-gegner
also diese Impfgegner die haben da ganz
komische Behauptungen aufgestellt und da
musste der Lauterbach ja mehr oder
weniger sagen das ist nebenwirkungsfrei
damit nicht gesagt er hat einen Fehler
gemacht das habe aber eben gesagt
daraufhin durfte musste er das so sagen
damit die Leute gar nicht okay das das
mitziehen und das finde ich eben das
Schlimme wir sind in dieser es sind
alles verteufelt worden Menschen auch
dass sie sagen die haben gesagt das ist
gefährlich wie kann man sowas sagen das
ist Meinungsfreiheit in dass Menschen
Angst hatten vor dieser Impfung dass
keiner wusste wie diese Impfung ausgeht
dass keiner wusste und zu dir immer
gesagt wenn wir keine Impfpflicht
bekommen wenn wir alle sterben so hat es
Lauterbach ich sage es mal übertrieben
immer wieder betont es war eine
Panikmache wir hatten alle Angst ich war
auch froh dass die im Stoff aber
dreimal geimpft ich habe Corona auch
gehabt
wir sehen doch heute das ist doch total
Quatsch gewesen ist eine Impfung
sprechen dann aber wirklich Unsinn ist
ein großer Unterschied
sagen Lauterbach kann das einfach mal
sagen es ist ein falsches Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich ja das
ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei uns nein
natürlich sehr schade für unsere Runde
da es geht hier in dieser Sendung und
dafür das muss ich Ihnen liebe zuschauen
und Zuschauer sagen ganz klar darum dass
wir hier eine offene Debatte führen dass
hier jeder sagen kann was er denkt
gerade das Thema der Pandemie ist ein
hoch emotionales Thema ganz ganz viele
Menschen haben gelitten und ich glaube
wir müssen alle daran arbeiten da
transparent zu werden und da auch
aufzuklären und genau das soll hier in
dieser Sendung auch passieren deswegen
finde ich es persönlich besonders schade
wenn jemand nicht mehr Teil dieser
Diskussion sein möchte das respektieren
wir ich hoffe meine gestern trotzdem
weiterhin Freude daran diese Debatte
weiterzuführen vielleicht wollen sie
aufrutschen damit ich hier nicht so
einsam Sitze das würde mich freuen von
Herr Lutz
ich finde das sehr bedauerlich denn ich
denke es ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Thema wir sprechen weiter darüber und
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass wir
darüber ganz offen diskutieren können
deswegen bedauerlich aber wir machen
weiter